the Joe Rogan experience I'm gonna go
down there and work on another book what
do you what do you write now uh you know
it's kind of under wraps because I
talked about this book way too much and
it slowed me down so about Neil Young's
bed can we cut that out
get a guy in trouble for saying that you
remember the first I was on this show
how [ __ ] up it was at the beginning
what were you even aware of that what
happened so the first time I came on the
show I didn't know you right and I
didn't know anything about you because I
was living in Spain and Duncan I done
Duncan shows the first time I done a
part I didn't know what a podcast was I
came to LA to visit my parents I have
his email from Duncan I'm a comedian you
want to do a podcast I'm like sure never
met a comedian don't know what a podcast
is so I did it and we had a good time
and after he's like uh you know I'd love
to introduce you to my friend Joe Rogan
I think you guys would get along and you
could do his podcast I'd never heard of
Joe Rogan right and no insult intended I
just I lived in Spain I didn't ever
watch Fear Factor I'd your whole thing
was happening over here I didn't know
about it and then I went back to Spain I
was like okay Duncan's friend Joe does
this podcast in his living room the way
Duncan does I assumed right and I went
back to Spain and I was talking to my
buddy voodoo who's the tattoo artist and
he's like so how was LA oh yeah cool it
did a podcast with his comedian it was
really fun and interesting and he's like
oh you should do Joe Rogan's podcast I'm
like dude how do you know
Duncan's friend Joe right there's this
whole weird things like no dude Joe
Rogan's will be so I tried to tell you
that story
the first time I came and the point of
the story is I'm an idiot I don't know
what's going on right I'm oblivious but
we got to the point where I said I
didn't know you and you were like so
would you do Google me and I was like
well not really and then and then we had
to do a sound check or you had to do an
ad or something and it got the story got
interrupted and I felt like you thought
I was trying to dis you or something I
definitely didn't yeah well I was
paranoid then you
little joint the joint around oh yeah
and I'm like [ __ ] if I don't hit this
joint that I'm confirmed [ __ ] here so
I hit the joint even though I hadn't
smoked any weed in months and it was
this like California weed I'm holding
literally I remember I'm holding the
bottom of my chair trying not to fall
out of the chair and and we start
talking and I'm telling the story about
a dude that I had met on an airplane and
he was super into sex at dawn and then
we were gonna do a movie together and
whatever and then his wife like took the
book away from him do you remember oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah and and then I was
just like oh [ __ ] I shouldn't have told
that story that you know this this whole
I'm [ __ ] everything out and I said to
you can we just because we're like five
minutes in at this point and it's like
Joe can we just like cut this and start
over and you looked at me he said is
live [ __ ] you don't remember any of
that I do now man I knew the guy yeah
yeah exactly and you were like to say
his name and then I said his name you're
like he's a friend of mine and I'm like
oh [ __ ] I should have said his name and
the whole thing yeah and then I left
Kissel des was here in the studio and we
left we got in the car and I said man
was that as awkward as I felt and she's
like that's the worst I've ever seen you
establish a great friendship yeah yeah I
don't know maybe you enjoyed what should
we suffer I don't know I do enjoy
watching people get too high it's not a
suffer thing it's like I've been there
it's a commiseration thing I think I uh
one of the things about these sober
October things is you realize like
there's so many things that are so much
easier when you're not high yeah you
know it's almost like you handicap
yourself by getting baked like yeah well
I was talking to red band
Brian red band about this we were
talking about like how the early days of
podcast we would get obliterated before
we do the podcast like for you
years like up until like maybe two
thousand thirteen or fourteen like we
would I had a volcano you know it fills
up this bag and you take do these big
deep hits off this THC vapor and then as
soon as you put the bag down and we'll
okay let's get going
let's start the podcast and be like oh
my god what have we done and it was this
feeling every time we did the podcast
was oh my god what have we done and
you'd be in the middle of saying
something and as you're saying like what
am I talking about yeah I don't even
know what I'm talking about and then you
would say oh no no it's not that like
you would screw things up you get
scrambled in your head when there's no
pot at all that never happens like you
mean you might make mistakes but you
know what you're talking about while
you're talking about it right like when
you're really really high like that
there's a lot of times where you're
talking about stuff will you literally
don't know exactly what you're talking
about yeah it's like that split
personality thing we were talking about
it really marijuana has so many pros but
it's got some cons like everything in
life like like and good things and bad
things and food and sleep there's pros
and cons and then the cons become very
evident when you're not doing it you
know I still think every time I do these
sober October things I always think well
I'm gonna cut back I'm gonna cut back on
some weed and I think I did last year
like after October I was like I am NOT
gonna do it as much as I used to do it
[Applause]